[Musique]
végétaux mais que les conseillers aussi
d'avoir la main verte allez allons à ça
bonjour monsieur Gilot alors bonjour
monsieur comment allez les là tu
chantais doucement doucement alors
mon trésor c'est mon petit jardin créole
on a toute qualité fleur avec des petits
arbres Gambetta et monana médicament
pour moins boire le soir et puis des
trucs pour manger derrière la maison
mais il fait mon petit jardin potager
mon papa te
cultivateurs
et là c'est la santé en tout cas elle
est vraiment Gaïa et Monsieur cadet
est-ce que
tu domine connu en tant que botaniste
dans la maison et puis à boire son café
[Musique]
le plus bas et le monsieur Morin il
vendait sa petite maison et qu'en lui
vendait bah lui dit non moi
il pleut à mon pied de maison là moi la
droite du monde pour tout la nuit mon la
levé moi
ôtez ou la trappe la case sur le bord la
route ou là à l'identité là il y a des
montagnes
et moi les numéros Montagny là mais
depuis ce temps la monnaie dedans
monsieur Cardi Bale est exceptionnelle
c'était l'histoire est-ce que demain
souvenir en particulier quand on imagine
il fait un émotion un peu spéciale on
l'avait mis camarades on m'avait une
table pour amusant de tous les dimanches
nous te souhaits dedans jusqu'à temps
après bon c'est ça qui l'a prise de
particuliers et même maman voilà et moi
mais entretien jusqu'à tant mieux ok
c'est bien bien
quel endroit pour faire le plus haut de
case l'ordre mais pour faire le plus
c'est près de mon moral
et quelques télé juste devant ma cuisine
de bois là-bas je me suis calé alors
c'est lui le matin
[Musique]
et puis au revoir à la prochaine salut
un magnifique trésor son jardin créole
et un gage histoire son cases mais il
est pas fini moi même ça a continué
[Musique]
ma beauté ma pote est loquée à mon
moment
ça me soulier
puis mon claque